[Music]
we're going to go through a few examples
we're going to start with a specific
team the double attack and we're going
to see whether you guys are going to
find the right solution along the way or
not and we're also going to discuss
about the games in general they're going
to be short games so hopefully it's
going to go according to plan
the first game efore c6 how do we call
this opening guys it's already well
known opening one of the main lines this
is called the CARICOM the CARICOM
defense it's a very popular opening you
know we have c5 which is the Sicilian we
have the e5 the open games and many more
I don't think it's a foolish thing to do
because you're actually attacking the
center on some degree you're attacking
the you're attacking the squared d5 more
or less you're supporting your advance
with a deep one d5 right it's okay it's
it's a pretty good opening very
strategic it usually leads to very
strategic positions long maneuvering
games but this particular example is not
going to be long and there's not going
to be a lot of maneuvering d4 d5 both
white and black are trying to cap rate
the center Knight c3 it takes D takes d4
Knight takes e4 Knight f6 so far so good
this is the main line Queen d3 this is a
very strange move to be honest do we
generally want to get the Queen out
quickly
not really right so can somebody tell me
a few better moves in this position a
few of them we have a lot of candidates
yes
Bishop to d3 would be one absolutely
anything else well actually I'm looking
at Bishop d3 what can black do what's
the consequence of the move Bishop d3
yes yes
right that could be a possibility that's
why he played Bishop d3 right to defend
this this night the problem is there is
a big consequence and that is it stopped
the action of the Queen on the d5 so
right now this pawn is no longer
protected right I can just simply take
it with my queen white still probably
has some compensation because of the
fact that he gets his pieces out quickly
in the game with Knight f3 everything
who is with tempo I'm going to attack
the Queen I'm going to force it to go
back but still is going to be material
down it's going to be a pawn down the
black is doing fine in that position
after Queen takes d4 so he played Queen
d3 which is not which is not very good
if I've an interesting idea D takes d5
what was the point then he just the he
just gave away upon or yes absolutely
does black have any way of regaining his
pawn
you could take the Queen but if you take
the Queen and I'm just simply going to
take back with the bishop and in the
same time I'm going to defend my knife
right so you're just going to be Queen
for Queen - that's going to be an
exchange nobody's going to win anything
and you just sacrificed one point yes
Queen a5 check exactly and that is what
we call a double attack yeah
why it will go Bishop to d2 Queen takes
e5 long castle is this a good move
yes well yes or not and if you say yes
then you also have to tell me why
No okay so you don't have an idea yet
yes it's protecting the king of course
that's that's one good reason for it the
problem is there is a critical question
that we have to answer and that is one
of our pieces is no longer protected
which one is that yes the night only for
very good so now there are some
questions we have to answer black has a
few options right
what are his main options is that Arjun
you're not answering any questions Arjun
Arjun is like way above a thousand level
he's around 2000 so he knows most of
these things
somebody else I see some raisins yes
mm-hmm
good question what happens after 94
first of all to be honest let's start
with Queen takes e4 those are black's
biggest biggest possibilities biggest
options take the night with a queen or
take the night with the night we have to
answer both of them let's start with
taking Knight with a queen yes rook to
e1 exactly that's the point
so if black takes with the Queen now we
see the fact that the king and the queen
are on the same file so we can take
advantage of that we can pin the Queen
we don't have to exchange the Queen we
can just pin it now the Queen will be
lost right the Blessed that the best
black can do is to just sacrifice this
Queen for the rope then we're going to
take back with the with a bishop and
who's going to have the material
advantage why yeah all right now the
more difficult question arises that is
what happens after Knight takes e4 you
have to calculate guys it's not that
easy so when you have an answer you try
to give me the whole variation please
yeah yeah
route 31 is an option the problem with
rookie one is I'm just going to differ
my knife and with f5
and most probably I'm not going to save
my night that's true
but you're not going to get more than
just my night you're probably going to
have to be forced to play f3 you're
going to regain your night because I no
longer have the option of moving it
there the queen is unprotected on e5 the
problem is you're not going to get more
than that what if I tell you in this
position white actually can win by force
in three moves with a tactical shot
it's forced checkmate in three moves all
right who wants to give it a shot
all right so what he wants to do is
sacrifice the Queen with Queen d8 King
takes d8 and now we see the double
attack and that is Bishop to g5 yeah
discovery check double attack however
you want to call it there's plenty of
ways to call it now black has two
options he can go to ei or he can go to
D to C 7 how are we going to respond to
each one of them yes
mmm-hmm Bishop to d8 very good and this
is a checkmate right the rookie is
protecting the bishop the bishop is
protecting the escape of the black King
on b6 right he cannot go there and he
cannot go on D 7 or D 6 because the rook
is there to protect those squares right
so the black king is simply in checkmate
who sacrifice the Queen we sacrificed a
knight we sacrificed a lot of material
but we got the King out and everything
was forced now
what if he goes King EE somebody that
hasn't answered before yes in the back
in the red uuuuu in the red yep
rogue da track mate very good and that's
game over
all right this one was pretty easy okay
let's go to the next one efore ePHI f4
how do we call this mm-hmm he takes f4
was the point of the Kings gambit was
the strategy behind it kind of sure tell
me
no no I know I concrete moves for sure
d4 but I want to know the strategy
behind it like what are you trying to
accomplish with white by sacrificing
this point what are the advantages of
sacrificing this pawn
sure tell me you yeah
to control the center yes and to get
your pieces out with temple right you're
going to go D for you you're attacking
the pawn on f4 if black is going to try
to defend that pawn he's going to lose
some time and so on right we're trying
to gain momentum we're trying to gain
time we're trying to get our pieces out
as soon as possible and in the same time
attack the center of a cap rate the
center Knight of three was played there
are a lot of ways of playing Knight f3
is one of them d4 is a is another one of
them Bishop c4 is another one of them I
think d4 is a little bit hasty at the
moment because of what move yes Queen h4
check exactly Queen h4 check and now we
have to get our King out to eat or d2 or
play the move g3 the problem is if we
play g3 we go here and after an
interesting idea such as a knight each
Knight f3 what can black do he has a
very powerful move in this position
pawn to g2 exactly he's going to leave
his queen unprotected but he's going to
get another Queen after Knight takes h4g
th one we're getting another Queen on
the board and this is decisive advantage
for black clearly decisive advantage
move back so that's why D for
immediately is not as good we have to
protect that square h4 we can either do
that with Knight f3 or also I think
Bishop c4 is an option and if you do
something such as Queen h4 I'm simply
going to put my king to f1 then my
knight is going to come with tempo on f3
and I'm going to push our pieces back my
King is quite safe on f1 and slowly
slowly I'm going to be able to regain
the pond get my get the King to f2
potentially the route goes to e1 on the
central squares and so on I'm going to
create a castle out of more than one
move yeah
just king of Tour rookie one king g1 and
so on but Knight f3 is the main line d5
Knight c3 so as you can see white has
has gotten his pieces out quite quickly
in the center yeah he already got his
knights out while while black is still
kind of uh underdeveloped Bishop g4
Queen e2 and I want you guys to tell me
if Bishop f3 is a good move
Arjuna I know you know I'm aware of that
mm-hmm yes yes yes
the question was is Bishop f3 a good
move Bishop takes f3 the knight a good
move exactly that's that's the reason
why Bishop f3 is not good because we
don't have to recapture on f3 with our
queen or our pawn we can just simply
give this discovery check double attack
Knight f6 and now the king is in
checkmate
right yes what is your question what's
causing the checkmate is the Queen and
the knight both attack the King at the
same time so whenever that happens the
only way to respond to to such a threat
is to move the King the problem is you
cannot move the King anywhere I think we
have time for one more a bit more of a
complicated game let's see if I find it
around here yes okay so we're going to
discuss a little bit about the
principles of the middle game everybody
knows what to do I hope everybody knows
what what they have to do in the opening
what are the principles of the opening
you tell me one you tell me another one
take control of the center anybody else
yes you have an answer hmm develop your
pieces absolutely and let's add another
one yeah yes your King to safety very
good those are the core of what you need
to do in the opening of course you also
have to make the connection between the
rooks put the rooks in the center and so
on there's a lot of principles that we
can abide by but what do we do in the
middle game when the opening face has
finished let's
Knight takes d4 and this is the position
I want you guys to think about for a
second and try to try to give me a few
candidate moves
one thing that you will always need to
try to do once the opening phase is
finished is to actually improve the
quality of your pieces okay so what that
means is put them on better squares more
active squares squares closer to the
opponent's king and try to involve all
your forces into the attack right in the
same time you have to kind of diminish
the quality of your opponent's pieces
now the question is how are we going to
achieve that as white in this position
what piece we can improve what pieces we
can improve and how are we going to
concentrate our forces towards our
opponents King this is not easy
the be honest this is a question that
deserves at least five to ten minutes of
thought but I'm going to ask we're going
to try to go along a little bit faster
than that yes in the back Bishop a4 is
is is a very natural move we're just
simply developing our pieces right I
think you guys saw already the answer
hopefully you didn't but even if you did
you'll have to explain it to me anyway
Bishop a4 very natural move the problem
is I'm just simply going to play
something like Queen d7 then you're most
probably going to have to retreat then
I'm going to go rook to e8 I don't
really have any weaknesses yeah as black
black doesn't have any structural
weaknesses his pawns are perfectly fine
what is the only drawback in blacks
position what is the differentiator in
in the position what gives white a
slight advantage
nope well you could say it like that as
well but there's a different word for
that yeah yeah you mm-hmm
you you yep the bishop is trapped no
there is no trouble bishop the bishop is
a little bit passive yeah it's not
trapped its passive but he has ways of
getting him out he can go some like
bishop faith then maybe g6 Bishop g7
there are ways along the way to get that
bishop active no the biggest problem in
in the position for black is that he
doesn't have as much space as white oh
okay a lot of people were probably going
to say that that's okay why is that
because this point is more advanced than
this point right this point is already
enjoying a presence in the center while
this guy is on the sixth rank and is
accommodating blacks position blacks
peace movement right so that's why why
it is slightly slightly better in this
position but Bishop f4 is not the right
move you have a better way of improving
the quality of your pieces and getting
the pieces by force closer to blacks
King in the meantime you're also going
to create some weaknesses in blacks
position
so you
somebody that hasn't answered yet most
of you have answered very very few that
haven't sure Bishop g5 that's also
natural move but again it doesn't
necessarily accomplish anything
immediate yeah
Bishop g5 again is a very natural move
you're just developing your pieces
getting ready to put your route to d1
and so on
argent
this is one of the few times I will let
you answer you've seen this game before
I'm letting you answer and you already
saw this game before okay say it Quincy
three very good now explain to me why
Quincy three you're attacking the C pawn
so he's forced to worry about that
problem at the moment he doesn't have
time to finish his development okay okay
okay okay okay enough good
good let's let them give them a bit of
space c6 so you're improving the quality
of your pieces where does this Queen
want to go why is this Queen better
placed on c3 there on d4 worried she
trying to to go yes
blue shirt mm-hmm that's here that's
here to g3 most probably right
closer to blacks King in the same time
what other piece is going to join the
fray
what other piece pieces quality is going
to be improved no oh
the bishop again we can we can get it
out at any moment right we're going to
wait actually the bishop is improved
right now because the d6 pawn is a
weakness this point from c7 is no longer
defending the d6 pawn so this Bishop is
going to have a clear purpose when we
put it potentially to f4 and attack the
pawn on d6 right so sure the bishop is
also improved in the last move but there
is a different piece that has a new
route at at its disposal
no sir
you're answering my question with
another question will we are going to
see what happens then I mean that's long
in the future I was just asking you what
other piece is being improved with the
smoke Queen c3 red shirt how is the
route being improved
but you could have played Quinn
purgatory before also now it's the night
guys
it's the night on b5 why why is she
getting improved by this move Queen c3
where does he want to go
Disick's no he wants to go to have five
guys he wants to go to d4 and then to f5
and then in in cooperation with the
Queen which is probably going to go to
g3 he's going to attack on g7 right so
94 was play 97 black is trying to
improve the quality of his pieces as
well he's going to try to bring this
bishop to f6 and this night potentially
in the center yeah it's just trying to
kind of activate his pieces as well
Knight to a5 Bishop f6 Queen to g3 you
see when you're following a plan
generally the moves come much much
easier yeah so always create a plan in
the middle game that's extremely
important don't play just just for the
sake of playing and play kind of
automatic moves try to have a plan that
you're going to follow once the middle
game starts 925 all right so now comes
the question why our Bishop of Bishop h6
is not such a good move how can black
defend
yes
how can black defend there's only one
good way of defending against Bishop
takes juice mm-hmm
yeah yeah well if you play g6 I'm going
to capture your rook yeah
and that's going to be an exchange up
for me so that's not a good way of
defending we have a much better way of
defending yes Knight to g6 exactly
Knight to g6 just disrupt disrupting the
action of the Queen on g3 right
the Queen is no longer pinning this pawn
on g6 it's actually with tempo because
right now we're threatening to take the
bishop on h6 for threatening to gain a
piece so what white has to do is retreat
and black simply has gained a good
defender on g6 and the tempo so it's
definitely a bad bad move for white
instead of that the bishops placement is
much better on f4 because we're going to
focus on this newly created weakness on
d6
right Queen c7 roof d1 route d8 all
right now comes the calculation almost
all our pieces are what basically all
our pieces are on their best squares
they have the maximum potential
what to do when that happens when all
our pieces are active when all our
pieces are on their best squares we
usually have to start looking for
tactical shots combinations be careful
be careful is not easy to be honest the
variation the ensuing variation is I
think around seven moves deep quite a
few moves so you have to look ahead a
lot
well ragda Therese is a normal natural I
mean natural move but I already told you
that to be honest your pieces are
already on their best squares you have
to look for tactical shots rugby too is
a normal move the problem we wrote it
too I think also Knight takes Knight c4
is is something that you might have to
deal with and I don't know if you're
going to like it because I'm threatening
the rope and the pond um b2 so if you go
back right now I'm going to take with an
item b2 and I'm simply going to gain a
pot it's not good not good enough I'll
give you a hint I'll give you the first
move Rob takes d6 what are you thinking
of that one okay so tell me the
variation then let's say black goes root
x d6
[Music]
okay
and then you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to play rook to d1
now you have to be careful you have a
winning variation but there is only one
continue if you take the rook black will
have a few options probably the most
important one that you have to deal with
is Bishop takes e5 after rook takes d1
Bishop takes e5
you have to be very very precise it's
it's a form of combination Arjun you
know the game you know the game you're
you're trying to be tricky
no leave your hand leave your hand Arjun
there's no one move checkmate
if you play Queen takes g7 Bishop takes
g7 and I'm simply just gaining a queen
so you have to be a little bit more
precise than that pay attention pay
attention to all the geometry in the
position
you guys have you guys in the back with
the hands raised you have the whole
variation okay let's let them think for
a little bit longer I want everybody to
have a chance to find the solution so
I'm going to give you another few
minutes I'm going to give you three
three three more minutes so focus hard
focus intensely
leave the hand down
two more minutes
mm-hmm
yeah
strong pieces
one Mormon
all right all the way in the back
because you haven't answered yet so you
go ahead tell me the whole variation
night to h6 that's a check can he take
it back no because it's pin the pawn on
g7 is pin so first move is to go King to
h8 continue Queen takes e5 the
interesting idea you're giving up the
Queen now I'm forced to take it back I'm
going I'm going to accept your sacrifice
continue rock to da
No now I'm going to take your night
you're going to take my rook I'm going
to move King g7 and I'm going to have a
huge material advantage a queen for look
that's bad somebody else yes red shirt
Knight takes f7 everything has to be
forced again guys remember that
everything has to be force troop d6 was
simply not a forced move yeah rook d8
was not a forced move either this is a
check everybody suddenly got enlightened
King to g8 Knight takes e5 and that's
that's just a piece and two pawns up
that's a clear winning advantage so
black has to accept your last sacrifice
rook takes f7 and now the problem is he
no longer has any defenders so we're
gonna go up the 8th route d8 and now the
king is defenseless you have to
sacrifice both your pieces with Queenie
8th route take C 8 raka fate Luke takes
the faith and as just game over
checkmate right so you see always in the
middle game this is what you need to
strive to achieve improve the quality of
your pieces get your piece is closer to
your opponent's king try to create a
plan okay and use all your forces for
the same goal do not just go away with
one of your one of your pieces like a
lone striker into the attack it's going
to get captured and it's not going to be
efficient you have to use all your
pieces to get to your opponent's king or
to your opponent's weaknesses for that
matter yeah
it doesn't have necessarily to be the
king it can also be just a weakness
weakness a structural weakness as long
as you use all your forces towards a
particular goal
[Music]